[Music]
in an amazing
case of self-sabotage
uh this guy wants to go on a police
ride-along
i guess he just felt like it so he does
a sign up when you do a police ride
along you just have to submit a formal
request to whatever department you want
to go
and uh they do a standard background
check let's see you along that's it they
do the background check they find out
this guy has two child rape allegations
oh god he shows up to the right along
and they arrest him right there wow
damn well he's obviously
r-worded if you know what i mean
yeah yeah yeah i mean for lack of a
better word yeah that's all i can think
of
in my very dense uh vocabulary
it still started with an r ended with an
e d which is perfect
i think if you have an outstanding
record and you're wanted you're not
you're gonna want you should avoid the
cops but instead this guy wants to do
right along like i haven't gotten caught
and i want to feel like i want to feel
like what it is to get caught yes yes
i blame kevin hart and ice cube
had they never made that movie this guy
probably would have never gotten
inspired
yeah what are the odds that this guy saw
that movie i didn't even know that that
was the thing i thought ride along was
an original piece of conte original
piece i didn't know that right along you
could just like yeah i thought like they
got to be homeboys or have a homie who
was like
in the police academy and you're like
i'm going to do a ride along as a part
of my uh requirements to be a police
officer just be a regular person i could
just sign up yeah you want to try it
let's do it i would i would have loved
to been on a ride-along chasing oj like
we're just like i could just join in on
this [ __ ]
then just like be like holy [ __ ] we're
in it right now that's the bronco yeah
yeah bro
what's another cry would y'all have like
been
your dream right along the dream title
as it came out i was like oh that's a
good question and i think we should
explore it all right your dream right
along dream right along i mean the oj
one's hard to beat when they when they
got bin laden
i would have been a dope right along
right they should have put a gopro on a
dog it was a [ __ ] led guy we all
could have watched the [ __ ] yeah
but i bet they did and then but everyone
got nauseous because it just kept moving
[Laughter]
what
this is like a black guy at a movie
theater you're just yelling out randomly
yo there he is there he is
they don't know we're coming god damn it
oh you want me to whisper i gotcha
the military doesn't have things like
that you're like the only one in like
playing clothes with the bulletproof
vest well everyone knows like in
tactical gear and you're like dude do
you guys do this a lot like flip-flops
should i worry everyone has like night
vision goggles on you're like i can't
even see you have to hold somebody
i understand why i can't get a gun but
can i get one of them cameras
hey guys i think he's fine he's good hi
guys guys
dude recording right there yo y'all are
odin right now
you guys are a little crazy
forcing it
or you know i'd like to be on a
ride-along um any time they go catch a
white
you ain't shooter
shoot him
seriously
no one's drawing their guns really dude
i would love to be on one of those
well so he just gets to walk out oh
we're gonna oh we're giving him a burger
what are we doing you're like following
the tray it was like you're
really feeding him this right now can i
get something like shut the [ __ ] up what
do you want to eat what do you want to
eat can i get a whopper he's in the car
with you because you're in the right
along he's with you you're just like you
[ __ ] just like that huh it's
like you and you see something you don't
cover them in the front you can put a
jacket over the cuffs like we don't know
what's going what is going on right now
dude it's okay if people see him in
cuffs yeah they put a neck pillow on him
lapd neck pillow he's getting better
treatment than the ride-along
we need a peanut butter jelly for lunch
why am i going in the backyard
why does his bulletproofist say don't
shoot like what's going on
straight up so protected oh
but yeah that's how easy it is to do
these ride alongs you just pick a police
department submit a request and then
they'll schedule you isn't that cool
yeah
a writer i guess okay in a real a
realistic
legit answer would be i would want to go
to the police station to do it right
along with the most racist cops that'd
be cool like that'd be cool i want to go
with the swastika guy on is that armed
yeah yeah that's the one i want that's
the one i want
[Laughter]
to ride with him just wanna see what his
day's like
he's just beating up minorities all day
oh this is uh this is what if you what
if that's just a box you can check on
the form it's not even like an actual
request like oh you want a racist cop oh
yeah
check that one right here i'll take
corrupt officer
that's that's the one i wanted yeah
that's crazy i was just about to go in
the car right now come on in yeah
let's go let's go
yeah
or or you get the training day [ __ ]
cop you know what i mean your training
style and you see [ __ ] denzel in the
front seat you're like oh this is cool
because you could just be on the
sidelines like oh [ __ ] he's gonna [ __ ]
you over he's wild
i just want to see him clap um like
stacks of cash together yeah welcoming
me you know like uh wow what's her face
um ava mendez naked that that'd be great
that's a great welcome that'd be eva
mendes was so hot mm-hmm
i write a lot right along at that
i couldn't even say it right along with
that we were all nervous we're all like
oh you think we'd actually be able to go
inside or we have to wait from the car
like a dog in the back seat just like
damn i could i wish i could [ __ ] see
a titty here yeah i'm pretty sure in
actual ride-alongs you do just stay in
the car you can't you can't get out yeah
i don't give a good or nothing i want to
like
i want to um i kind of fantasize about
saving cops like if i'm in a ride-along
we're like yeah like like let's say like
i'm in a ride-along and i'm just like oh
this is so cool you know and then so
they go out and they're like freeze
[ __ ] and then like they get shot and
i'm like oh [ __ ] here's my time and i
pull out the shotgun in the middle yeah
and i go out and i [ __ ] save them
yeah and you're like oh my god you're a
great shot and you're like thanks man
you're trying to get the keys to the i
get the keys to the city an honorary
batch yeah and then they you know how
like sometimes when a german shepherd
does well he gets the [ __ ] like metal
and stuff yeah i want to do that like i
want to stand there get the medal and in
the keys to the city it'd be like you
saved the officer number one volunteer
of all time number one volunteer that's
a pretty funny fantasy man
it's one of those shots too you're just
like hell of nervousness it's just like
i don't know i just can't
happen to land on it yes that's
beautiful look at lighty you're not
white you're not getting any medals
you'll probably get arrested for taking
an officer's shotgun and then shooting
it that's well maybe i'll do it in
monterey park where all the cops are
here that's true that is true yeah
that's something that is good yeah
that's true that'll work yeah i'll go to
cupertino or some [ __ ] you know i gotta
do the one of the you know that's a cool
that's a cool ride-along too to go on
with two uh asian cops yeah so that we
could do all the bad stuff that white
cops do to us yeah to white people yeah
yeah yeah maybe in hawaii we'll we'll
have to do a ride-along in hawaii yeah
like
hey where are you coming from why where
are you going why and then you could
just switch clothes and wear his uniform
and the department would know the
difference difference it'd be awesome
dude imagine you are two asian cops
though and then like white cops come
over and they're like what the [ __ ] they
took the cops out of their clothes and
put on the cops
they're like stop impersonating officers
first dating one or two white people in
the backseat
seriously
because lapd is so large that could
happen i bet you that's happened it does
look really weird when you think about
it yeah two asian cops and two white
guys in the back dude it just looks like
it was like they switched outfits this
is jackie chan scenes where he waits
around a corner and it just grabs a dude
and then he comes out in the same
clothes
and he's always in the janitor room like
[ __ ] in their boxers
and they're just wearing it next next
shot like dude it's like hey officer
smith how did you know that you know
they were fake cops oh see because when
we we we did the cop wave they went
and we just knew we just knew they
didn't do this
the cop wave yeah
they're like
so stupid
[Laughter]
oh
sorry to everyone that's not real
japanese this is japanese gibberish that
sounds good
wow
[Laughter]
no the [ __ ] ears is like yeah go
ahead dude
go ahead you see him
i'm all ears over here buddy i'm a fan
of asian accents
it'll help if you do this too while
you're doing it
because if you don't do this it's not
authentic then
if you're a brown guy and you have the
perfect asian accent dude you you
honestly i'll be honest with you i i do
agree with the idea if you nail it if
you nailed it and press it oh yeah i'm
saying then you nail it you don't say it
i don't have it to nail it i'm still
practicing so i can't stop that workshop
do you uh try it do you like work on it
by yourself at home absolutely
he does the eyes and everything in front
of the mirror
i do every every accident i like playing
you know trying to play with it it's fun
yeah yeah yeah
i like how you said nail it too because
isn't that one latina girl i always
forget her name dude the community they
did with the vietnamese angela johnson
yeah
it makes sense what she said because as
a as a woman going to nail salons that
is what you'll hear regardless of your
race like you're going to hear them talk
to you like that yeah you just call
yourself a woman you just call yourself
a woman no not me
it was very like you know the man that
knows a woman
because
at least one woman
like pronouncing like as a woman
uh
that's kind of our thing here
[Music]